["Bad Guy" playing]
[Billie] We made this album in a bedroom,
at our house that we grew up in.
♪ White shirt now red, my bloody nose ♪
♪ Sleepin', you're on your tippy toes ♪
♪ Creepin' around like no one knows ♪
♪ Can't stop starin' at those ocean eyes ♪
♪ So you're a tough guy ♪
♪ Like it really rough guy ♪
♪ Chest always so puffed guy ♪
-Is that million?
-Yeah.
Oh, my god.
♪ I'm that bad type ♪
♪ Make your mama sad type ♪
♪ Make your girlfriend mad tight ♪
♪ Might seduce your dad type ♪
Oh!
♪ I'm the bad guy ♪
♪ Duh ♪
The hook could be like,
"But I'm the bad guy".
Promise me that you're gonna vote.
I'm worried that when I
get a boyfriend,
I won't wanna
be with him because
I love Justin Bieber more.
And the Grammy goes to...
Billie Eilish!
♪ I'm only good at being bad ♪
♪ Bad ♪
Are you guys okay?
(crowd cheering)
You guys need to be okay,
'cause y'all are the reason I'm okay.
Okay?
♪ Hm, da-da-da ♪
♪ Da-da-da-da-da, hm, da ♪